de robe matin Dimitri fabienco les
pénuries de carburant en ce moment nous
donnent peut-être un avant-goût des
efforts qu'il va falloir consentir pour
passer l'hiver l'objectif fixé par le
gouvernement je vous le rappelle c'est
10% de consommation en moins d'ici 2024
cela revient à faire je vous donne le
chiffre 1 ça revient à faire 30 fois
mieux que ce que l'on a fait chaque
année depuis 20 ans on va prendre ce
matin l'exemple du secteur du numérique
bonjour Jean-Noël barreau bonjour
Dimitri Pablo bienvenue sur Europe 1
vous êtes le ministre délégué chargé de
la transition numérique et des
télécommunications vice-président du
modeg mais également je signale aussi
que vous avez été réélu député hier à
l'issue du second tour d'une élection
législative partielle dans les Yvelines
peut-être voulez-vous en dire un mot bon
écoutez c'est une satisfaction c'est
c'est un score qui nous honore et qui
nous engage à poursuivre le travail
engagé c'est aussi une une lourde
sanction pour la pour la nuit pêche qui
régresse de 7 points et c'est une
sanction contre un comportement qui
consiste à préférer le désordre au
au dialogue et puis l'obstruction plutôt
que le compromis donc tout ça j'espère
appellera un certain nombre de mes
collègues parlementaires à l'Assemblée
nationale de la nupesse c'est un peu de
responsabilité alors d'ailleurs je
signale aussi que c'est votre suppléante
donc qui siègera au Palais Bourbon
venons-en au plan de sobriété présenté
mercredi dernier Jean-Noël Barrault le
numérique évidemment est évidemment dans
la boucle quels engagement le secteur
va-t-il prendre et qu'est-ce que vous
gouvernement attendez de la filière du
numérique qui part définition est un
gros consommateur d'électricité oui je
crois qu'on attend de ce secteur comme
de l'ensemble des secteurs les efforts
nécessaires à réduire la consommation
énergétique pour que la France diminue
de 10% cette consommation à l'horizon
des deux ans et que nous puissions
traverser cet hiver et peut-être l'hiver
prochain sans avoir à prendre des
mesures de dernier recours et s'agissant
du numérique les acteurs ont avant l'été
prix de premiers engagement s'agissant
de la lumière dans leur bureau dans leur
commerce mais aussi de la température
dans leur dans leur euros et ils ont
pris de nouveaux engagements sur la mise
en veille automatique des box sur la
réduction de la consommation électrique
de leur réseau et puis pour certaines
entreprises du numérique exactement
l'engagement de faire un bilan carbone
dès l'année 2020 pour être en mesure de
réduire effectivement leur consommation
alors les box notamment alors ça en
l'occurrence ce sont les opérateurs
télécoms est-ce que ce sera transparent
pour le consommateur est-ce que lui va
avoir une différence dans l'utilisation
de de sa box Internet est-ce qu'elle va
s'éteindre toute seule la nuit piloter à
distance par l'opérateur c'est
l'objectif l'objectif c'est de
l'objectif c'est de internet la nuit
alors c'est de réduire la consommation
énergétique sans aller demander des
efforts trop importants aux Français il
existe aujourd'hui des des boxs des
décodeurs qui qui se mettent en veille
automatiquement mais tout cela n'est pas
tout à fait uniforme et donc les
engagements pris par le secteur et bien
c'est soit pour les box existantes déjà
installées et bien de faire une mise à
jour qui permet de mise en veille de
manière un peu plus systématique soit
pour les nouvelles box qui seront
distribués qui seront vendus que cette
mise en veille soit installée par défaut
pour que ça soit transparent
effectivement pour les Français alors il
y a le secteur ce qu'on appelle les Data
Center c'est-à-dire vraiment les centres
de données là on imagine que c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué puisque en
l'occurrence il faut une alimentation
électrique en continu pour que ça la
fonctionne ils se sont engagés à
s'effacer vous allez nous expliquer ce
que ça veut dire c'est facile c'est un
terme qu'on va beaucoup entendre c'est à
dire de se déconnecter du réseau en fait
tout simplement et de brancher à la
place des générateurs électriques qui
fonctionnent à quoi souvent au diesel
alors là la question que j'ai envie de
vous poser est-ce que c'est la sécurité
d'approvisionnement avant tout et tant
pis pour le bilan carbone vu la
situation oui alors il y a deux choses
qui se sont engagées à faire les Data
Center la première chose c'est de
réduire la climatisation dans les les
salles de serveur ces serveurs ils
chauffent il faut les refroidir et donc
ils vont faire un effort en baissant la
climatisation ce qui va permettre de
réduire la consommation énergétique
c'est pas périlleux pour justement les
les serveurs eux-mêmes non je crois que
là l'effort qui est fait ne met pas en
difficulté la sauvegarde des données
ensuite vous avez raison dans le cas où
nous serions amenés à prendre des
mesures un peu plus importantes il sera
en capacité de s'effacer c'est-à-dire de
basculer du réseau vers des générateurs
alors évidemment c'est pas une solution
idéale c'est pas une solution de long
terme puisque le générateur c'est la
roue de secours pour le si la route
secours crève on essaie de passer sur
une roue de secours mais c'est pas idéal
parce que la roue de cette cour comme
vous l'avez dit elle fonctionne en
général avec une énergie carbonée et ce
que nous voulons à terme c'est
décarboner intégralement le
fonctionnement des Data Center et
d'aller plus loin puisque le le data
center enfin les Data Center travaille
en permanence à essayer d'optimiser leur
fonctionnement pour réduire leur
consommation électrique et à long terme
nous souhaitons qu'il puisse le faire au
maximum mais c'est cet hiver en tout cas
baisse de la climatisation dans les
salles de serveurs et et le cas échéant
c'est à dire si ça s'impose un
effacement temporaire pour réduire la
ponction énergétique sur le réseau ça
représente quoi le secteur du numérique
en termes de consommation électrique
Jean-Noël baron électrique c'est 10% de
la consommation électrique du pays ah
oui tout de même et oui et donc c'est
pour ça qu'il faut faire cet effort et
vous leur demandez quel effort quelle de
diminuer par un tiers par deux alors
consommation alors c'est difficile de le
dire exactement mais c'est l'heure
de grandeur qu'on s'est fixé pour la
nation dans son ensemble c'est à dire à
peu près 10% à l'horizon des deux ans
alors il y a un autre sujet évidemment
pour les entreprises du numérique cela
vous concerne Jean-Noël Barraud c'est
dans votre périmètre c'est la question
du prix je vous donne l'exemple de
Laurent wonski le patron dervore alors
lui fabrique des compresseurs c'est pas
le secteur du numérique mais bon il est
client des énergéticiens lui dit c'est
simple mon mégawater je le payais 50
euros l'année dernière là son
énergéticienne va le contacter c'est
3000 euros le megawattheure c'est fois
60 comment on fait c'est ce que le
président de la République avec Bruno Le
Maire est en train de faire au niveau
européen c'est-à-dire de mettre fin à
cette situation très conjoncturel mais
très inquiétante pour les acteurs du
secteur du numérique comme comme pour
d'autres du fait de la très forte hausse
des prix du gaz qu'est-ce que vous
demandez à Bruxelles très concrètement
ce qu'on demande c'est de pouvoir mettre
fin si l'on peut dire au couplage du
prix du gaz et de l'électricité de fixer
un cap possible pour faire en sorte que
la pression baisse et que les prix
diminuent parce que vous avez cité les
entreprises du numérique mais j'ai aussi
dans ma circonscription beaucoup de
petites entreprises des TPE des PME
parfois des boulangers ou même un moulin
à Versailles
si vous demandez aux énergéticiens si
vous captez les prix vous dites vous
n'avez pas le droit de vendre plus cher
qu'est-ce qui va se passer sur les
marchés liquides type le GNL les bateaux
vont aller ailleurs qu'en Europe en se
disant les Européens veulent pas le
payer le plus de 180 euros bon très bien
allons ailleurs c'est vrai si nous
négocions donc les prix ou la pénurie
c'est vrai si chaque nation chaque État
membre de l'Union européenne négocie
dans son coin mais si l'Europe parle
d'une seule voix et c'est ce que nous
avons fait depuis quelques mois sur la
dette sur les vaccins si l'Europe parle
d'une Savoie elle peut avoir un impact
sur les prix c'est le le pari du
président de la République qui à mon
avis va fonctionner parce que il a
fonctionné ces derniers mois sur
d'autres grands défis je suis sûr que
nous parviendrons dans les semaines qui
viennent à faire baisser la pression sur
les prix de l'énergie en Europe merci
Jean-Noël barreau d'être venu ce matin
nous voir sur Europe 1 j'appelle que
vous êtes le ministre délégué et chargé
de la transition numérique et des
télécommunications bonne journée à vous
à vous aussi